wer so die war immer temporär und er war
auch immer nicht für die ewigkeit
geschaffen und jetzt mit
klassenkämpferischen parolen zu sagen
oder klassenkämpferische parolen
hervorzuholen zu sagen na die obersten
die reichen die sollen jetzt nicht in
den genuss kommen ist doch völliger
quatsch weil der so liebe angelegt als
unter temporäre unterstützungsmaßnahmen
für die neuen bundesländer die sind nun
das haben wir 2020 30 jahre nach
vollendung der deutschen einheit auch
nicht mehr neu
deswegen gibt es auch keine berechtigung
mehr für den soli einer für alle alle
für einen auch in diesem fall auch gilt
das auch für die erhebung des soli